So now that we have the dream solution,
and
we all decide it's best,
we move to prototyping, right?
>> That's right.
Prototyping is a wonderful
way to test your ideas.
In fact, we want to make prototypes
that are real enough to feel, so
that we can test them with users,
and that's all that's required.
Prototyping can take many forms.
The simplest is to do a paper prototype
where you can quickly gather feedback.
One level up from that is to work on
digital designs that are mid fidelity or
high fidelity.
The higher the fidelity the easier it is
to test and to get feedback from users
because they're looking something
that's a little bit more polished.
A next level of prototyping is
actually creating physical prototypes.
When we work on something like Project
Glass at Google or Project Moon, it's
not about software always, it's about
what does the physical device look like?
So that's when it's useful
to have materials that
help you create a quick
shape of a general idea.
Other prioritizes we
have made include video.
In fact, if you try to explain
the product to some one,
creating a video is super, super useful.
>> Yeah, Dropbox did that.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH] The little how to videos
that a lot of companies use to
describe their services are really
useful in the design phase.
If you make it straight on, even if
it's shot with a little mobile phone,
and the users are the friends
that you're working with.
That can be sufficient to explain the
idea to a user, or to an investor, and
to test it.
If you want the high quality prototype,
you need to spend longer developing it.
>> So I can actually code it.
>> That's right.
I think coding a prototype is a great
idea, so some people are able
to really sprint, and within two days,
start to already call the prototype.
And then you can have
an interactive demo.
Or some people take maybe four or
five days,
depending on how complex
the solution is.
So the duration of the prototyping
phase is usually what determines
the duration of the sprint.
This is the key aspect in which
actually the work is getting made.
If you're someone who loves to code,
who loves to design,
this is the phase that
you really get to shine.
And if you're looking for a low
fidelity prototype, a short sprint,
a few hours might be sufficient.
If you want something that's high
fidelity, or requires a demo or
a video, you're better advised to have
a whole week of the team's time so
you can make something beautiful.
>> How do I know which to choose, if I
choose a high fidelity or low fidelity?
What is the best?
>> Okay, so, if you're working on a new
product, it's probably best to shoot for
medium fidelity.
That means that you're not looking
at paper prototypes necessarily.
You might have some early wire frames,
and that you're starting
to put some color on them.
Or that you also use Keynote or
a quick prototyping tool that
your engineers know how to use in
order to bring some life to the ideas.
We believe in teams choosing
their own prototyping tools.
There's a lot that's
available on the market, and
the right ones are the ones
your team loves to use.
If you're wondering where to start,
Sketch is a really great example.
So is Adobe Suite, although it does
take a little bit of time to learn.
And then Keynote and
Google Sites are also really
useful in prototyping quickly.